pasaron semanas escondidos en refugios
como este sin luz agua con escasos
alimentos en el exterior una ciudad
completamente en ruinas
dentro oscuridad
[Música]
tenemos que salir de aquí de alguna
manera para hacer algunas reparaciones
pero como con que no hay materiales no
hay nada
con la toma del isi suns controlada
desde el domingo por las tropas rusas
muchos residentes incluidos menores y
ancianos siguen escondidos en los
sótanos abrumados por cómo van a
reconstruir sus hogares
el techo está roto tienes que arreglarlo
pero como lo pagas donde a quien el
invierno también llega pronto
antes de la guerra la urbe situada en el
noreste de ucrania albergaba a más de
100 mil habitantes
tatiana y su familia decidieron quedarse
pese a los intensos combates explica que
los aliados pro rusos de la región se
llevaron todas las banderas ucranianas
pero comenzaron a distribuir ayuda
humanitaria a los pocos residentes que
no habían huido ya mi familia yo no nos
fuimos a ningún lado porque en general
no podía garantizar la seguridad de los
miembros de mi familia en todo el
territorio ucraniano toda ucrania está
siendo bombardeada decidimos no
arriesgar nuestras vidas y quedarnos
aquí al menos en casa mieres cada
estrategia toma una vez controlada toda
la región oriental del uruguay
el kremlin busca ahora apropiarse de la
provincia de dónetsk intensificando su
ofensiva militar en slogans